good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about five ways to improve
your diet we have an awful awful reality
right now America you're at the top of
your game this is one of the most
unhealthy countries in the world can I
please just see a raise of hands for how
many of you had have children in this
room today please put your hands up
auntie's uncles you can continue to put
your hands up auntie's and uncles as
well most of you okay we the adults of
the last four generations have blessed
our children with the destiny of a
shorter lifespan than their own parents
your child will live a life ten years
younger than you because of the
landscape of food that we've built
around them two-thirds of this room
today in America are statistically
overweight or obese you lot you're all
right but we'll get your eventually
don't worry all right
the statistics of bad health are clear
very clear we spend our lives being
paranoid about death murder homicide you
name it it's on the front page of every
paper CNN look at homicide at the bottom
for God's sake right
every single one of those ones in the
red
it's a diet related disease any doctor
any specialist will tell you that fat
diet related disease is the biggest
killer in the United States right now
here today so I first principles to
super hydrate what we mean by that is
flushing your body with enough clean
water on a daily basis you know the
planet I mean water is life and the
planet itself is 70% water and even
within our own internal body our brain
is 75% water 76 actually our muscles are
75 and our bones are actually made up of
25% water so in a daily basis we need to
make certain that we're getting enough
hydration and you know the first symptom
of dehydration meaning your body doesn't
have enough water is not thirst I
suppose people think if you wait till
you're really thirsty to drink
you're really dehydrated that studies
show that 60 to 70 percent of the
population is dehydrated throughout the
day the number one symptom dehydration
is fatigue feeling tired so I see a lot
of people later in the afternoon maybe a
bunch of things and their body gets
dehydrated from just normal working out
or being around or just normal heat and
all of a sudden people are tired all the
time if you want to have more energy
which will give you fitness and will
give you health it'll make you strong
the first thing you want to do is super
hydrate drink more water we're not
talking about coffee we're not working
about cokes because those things have
water in them but they have other
elements in under there very acid and
when you have a lot acid in your body
your body's got to flush that acid out
where to stay balanced and so as a
result you don't keep hydrated so
hydration is critical just think of this
you're not just what you eat you're what
you drink and we'll give you a good
example we both sage night years ago had
a really great now we got a chance to
visit with Loretta's book is called the
body's cries for water the many cries of
the butterflies mini-crisis water excuse
me that's my man named after Batman
Gillen jolly mound floor I call him dr.
Batman for short he was cool of that but
dr. Batman was a medical doctor who
lived in Iran and during the fall of
Iran he became a political prisoner and
he was shipped into this place and then
all of a sudden there was a very high
official there that was very very ill in
the middle of the night you have peptic
ulcers and he was just reeling in
we're literally rolling on the ground
uncontrollable pain they have no
medication there because they didn't
care about the prisoners so they under
the threat of his like they said fix him
so he began to think well his body is
very acidic I'll flush his body with
water just that's all I have I don't
have any medicines to do this with so he
began a regimen of drinking this water
on this hourly basis and flushing his
mana within literally two hours a man
was completely out of pain and he's
blown away within 24 hours he's never
seen anything like this with any
medicine he'd ever applied so he became
fascinated since he was stuck in prison
they let him set up this little area and
he treated for three years more than
3,000 people with heart problems high
blood pressure you know a peptic ulcers
all just with water so even though it's
such a simple thing we take for granted
it's the most important thing in the
world I'll tell you one other quick
point if you want to lose weight this is
counter-intuitive drink more water
because most people do it they don't
want to you know they don't want to
drink water to think oh I'm gonna get
bloated but in fact when you don't give
your body enough water what the body
does is it holds on the water you have
and as a result of that you retain water
when the body sees you're giving it
enough hydration it'll let go of that
excess water and you'll actually see
weight loss so it's super important you
want a super hydrate so now what does
that mean super hydration what we mean
by that is you need to as a minimum
drink half your body weight in ounces so
myself I'm about 140 pounds so if you
split that in half that would be 70
ounces a day and that's just as a
minimum and you know I'll share one of
my own experiences as well it's really I
get a headache but if I ever do instead
of you know some people go and go to
grab tylenol grab Aspen I know I'm
dehydrated and I'll drink a full thing
of water and instantly that headaches
gone we say super hydrate we mean like
drink a large single order most people
you have this a symphony this much water
is gone I go I have some water you
really got to retrain your body because
our modern world has trained us to think
of water as being again that Coke that
coffee and it's not the same thing okay
a single thing that helped me the most
to click was not eating past 7:30 now
depending on what time you go to bed I'm
you're looking at that I mean not eating
a grape
not a grape not a rice or a crispy past
7:30 and the thing about it is I'd
started it at seven o'clock and then
just I was killing myself trying to get
home I remember we'd be talking she's
not gonna go I got is coming but it's
singular for a lot of people who making
bad food choices if you just do that
that will turn there's logic in that
yeah it's real it's magical if this just
it's just like just like you brush your
teeth you say 7:30 I do not eat past
7:30 and it the farther up you can move
that the better you get now this is the
key this is what really saved me I
remember you told me this day we're
walking around I went why the hell you
wait 10 years ago yeah okay Bob said to
me when you cut off your eating you cut
off your eating at least two to three
hours before you go to bed he goes that
little gnawing feeling you get that
little gnawing where you feel like I
feel like I need to eat something he
said that is when you are going into
your fat stores and you can either feed
that feeling give it food or you can say
oh this is when my body is going into my
fat stores and it's gonna now eat the
stored fat that's what that feeling is
and so what happens with most of us we
try to feed that feeling and then you
wake up and you're you you're back
you're back so what's your what you
really want to look for is that little
that it took ten years you've telling me
that we're walking I go you mean that's
it that's it that little thing that says
I want to eat something not I'm starving
but I wish and most of us what you do is
you go to the cabinet you open the
cabinets and you start grazing you gotta
go down this is what I've done before
you say is it rice krispy no is it oh
maybe it's on chocolate no let me try
have a pork chop no that one
but that's what you want you want to
feel like when you go to bed at night
you want to feel like I wish I could eat
a little something and that's the moment
when your body's going we're gonna go
into your butt now we're gonna pull out
of the thighs one of the most popular
New Year's resolutions is to eat a
healthier diet and the wife reason
people want to eat a healthier diet is
so that they can lose weight look better
and feel terrific
now there's a very simple system that I
call eliminate the three white poisons
the three white poisons in diet today
are white sugar white salt and white
flour and what you need to do is
eliminate all the foods that have those
three white poisons I was talking to a
friend of mine recently who I've worked
with for years and this time when I saw
I mean lost 25 pounds his clothes were
hanging on him like a tent I say what an
earth did you do to lose all the weight
he said I just followed your advice I
stopped eating anything that had sugar
in it no cokes no pastries no pies no
desserts I started eating eliminating
white salt I do not put salt on anything
and the reason is that everything
already has enough salt and the other
thing is I eliminated white flour
products it's interesting but this is an
enormous amount of research that says
your body it does not have the ability
to process foods that come from wheat or
grains which means pasta potatoes rice
and all forms of bread that are made
from white flour you just delete those
three and you'll have more energy you'll
have more confidence the weight will
fall off almost overnight and then make
it a lifelong habit make it a lifelong
habit just to refuse to eat the foods
that are not great for you it only takes
about three weeks to form a habit and if
you just stick at the hat to the habit
you week then and fit for life one rule
for weight loss that every diet must
understand is that they have to have a
breakfast with protein or fiber it if
you don't start up your day the right
way your metabolism
one big roller coaster all day long up
and down up and down you're never quite
we need to be then only way you eat more
but you won't function well either so a
high fiber or high protein breakfast
within an hour of getting up absolutely
essential try and eat foods that are
highly flavored and highly colored you
know if you eat seven colors of the
rainbow you're getting all the nutrients
that you need they're called
phytochemicals they're derived from the
energy of the Sun and they're found in
plants so you know plants and fruits and
vegetables have a lot of color
blueberries blackberries yeah there are
plants that are yellow like cauliflower
or cantaloupe or or other foods red blue
and green have the highest amount of
phytochemicals foods that are highly
colored are also highly flavored so if
you have a lot of flavors in your food
bitter pungent astringent then you will
get the full flavor of food but you will
also get the right phytochemicals in
many ethnic foods like in Mexican food
or Italian food or Indian food or
Chinese food all the ethnic foods have
six tastes and seven colors the six
tastes are sweet sour and salt bitter
pungent and astringent and any ethnic
food will have that we've created a
society where we emphasize sweet sour
and salt
french fries ketchup and hamburgers and
that creates a great imbalance in our
body because our body is crying out for
what nature intended for us all the full
complement of intelligence that's in
nature and so when you eat jalapenos or
you spice up your food with a little
garlic or ginger or red peppers or
tomatoes these things whilst they are
add flavor and color to your food
they're extremely healthy because they
have these phytochemicals they have
antioxidants they're what are called
anthocyanidins they have a lot of
nature's intelligence within you and
that nature
intelligence they have a they have a lot
of nature's intelligence in the food
itself which matches the intelligence in
your body because your body and the food
are part of the intelligence of the
universe so you're matching the
intelligence in nature with the
intelligence inside your body when you
eat something that comes out of a can or
has a label you can be sure it has no
life energy which is prana which is the
energy of the Sun in the phytochemicals
it's dead so don't try it any dead food
eat food that is alive and when you
start to eat consciously you'll find
that you'll enjoy food more you'll be
much more aware of the beneficial
effects of the food and you'll
spontaneously gravitate to the foods
that are good for you thank you so much
for watching I made this video because
Jeff mentor Jeff Mende I hope I
pronounced that okay asked me to so this
is a topic that you want me to cover in
the next edition of believe life leave
it in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do
I'd also love to know which other clips
meant the most to you and how you might
start making changes to your diet as
someone who's currently on a 30-day
challenge right now
I'm actually really curious to see the
changes that you're gonna make to your
diet and what you're working on right
now so leave in the comments below and I
will join in the discussion thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe I will see you soon
take some time and really learn how to
make healthy food you know I love to
cook and when we take time and we do you
know making salads and soups and
different things like that I love it I
love experimenting with different
flavors different ingredients all over
the world and when I do that it puts me
in a state of gratitude and it also puts
me in a state of understanding where my
food comes from and it helps me make
wiser decisions eating is something that
all of us have to do every single day
multiple times every single day so it's
important the more you learn the further
you're gonna get with learning this
valuable medium for life transformation
I usually start off with a shake in the
morning okay and then after that you
know probably like right before lunch I
start getting really hungry I have like
a little bit of fruit or you know a bar
or something like that and then I'll
have a lunch and it usually be something
yummy and again I don't like giving up
yummy food like that's a big deal for me
but it would be something like you know
chicken and salad or vegetables or
quinoa or something that McGann I
learned that doing the plant-based
program that I did and sorry that's
really good for you and then at night
sometimes I just eat whatever I want to
be honest so just like it's dinner time
I'm gonna have a good meal with my kids
I think a lot of it has to do with
portion control that's another thing
that I think people don't concentrate on
it's like I don't deprive myself of
things I you don't need to of your
practice yeah I just try to moderate it
a little bit so if I want to have you
know a little bit of rice and beans and
cuz that's what I grew up with and some
and some steak or whatever along the
first five ingredients you shouldn't
find sugar okay
now sugar supposed to beat and of course
but it should come together with either
fat or some element like fiber as you
would find in fruit so you can attack
you can absorb it a bit more slowly
number one so sugar is one of the first
five elements in whatever it is you're
buying it's a no no no no you want to
avoid it okay now even worse than sugar
even worse than sugar is this like
appetizing that is that is this is high
fructose corn syrup oh that's what it is
now it's at it's very sweet yeah but
it's not very good for you it's not good
for you because it blocks the
if a chemical called leptin which is the
way your fat tells you your brain isn't
exactly okay so you know what this is
the thing that's blocking it and so you
just keep eating and eating until you
literally stops right yeah it's not so
much even the 150 calories in the
Sodapop if you in fact that at that same
meal you will normally consume an extra
hundred calories of food and you would
have because of this because of this
okay high fructose corn syrup okay got
that these are both carbohydrates yes
the third carbohydrate is this yes this
is flour but it's enriched white flour
enriched right so why would they
enriched flour
the reason they enriched it is because
they already stripped out anything that
was worth a darn in it and they add a
little bit back so it doesn't look so
bad yes it should be whole-grain okay
wait till has those kernels it has this
B vitamins all the things you want to be
in there whole grains hip it's in it
okay so these three are carbohydrates
yes let's move on down to the fun stuff
okay now big confusion about fats yeah
big this is animal fat yes animal fat is
saturated saturated fat is from
four-legged animals good if it's coming
from a four-legged animal its saturated
so that means these things can be solid
at room temperature okay large things
are being done saturated think large
good oils good oils our oil our liquids
at room temperature repeating so I'm
putting into my brain okay now the thing
about good oils is that they're not very
stable if you put a good oil into a
cracker and try to store it on a shelf
it goes bad uh-huh because good oils
aren't very stable so in order to deal
with that problem
we took the good healthy vegetable oils
and we hydrogenated them we added
hydrogen's to them okay tell me that
again we took good healthy oils okay and
in order to make them solid yeah and
make them so they wouldn't go bad in a
year on a shelf somewhere aha we added
hydrogen's to that hydrogen right
hydrogen okay makes those flimsy things
become rigid and that's what I make it
stay on the shelf for a year well it
makes it solid at room temperature and
solid on a shelf for a year okay and
that's this this should be liquid
it's obviously not oh this is very good
for your skin and
you can actually use this kind of
material for furniture polish lots of
fun things yeah but don't put it in you
I can use it on my feet good I'm
thinking this is a great moisturizer the
bottom of my heel yeah okay and this is
what what is this lard no this this is
actually a hydrogenated oil okay it's
it's a material that is created so that
you can keep that stored material on
Michelle for long time here's the big
deal when you have healthy oils yeah and
you cook with them mm-hmm you oxidize
them you damaged them so the key thing
to know about the healthy oils and what
are the healthy oil olive oil sesame
seed oil there's they're all the ones
that are liquid when they're Clack seed
oil when they're cold right some are
better than others but generally the
ones I just listed
you know canola oil flaxseed oil olive
oil these are all very healthy oils but
because they're healthy they're very
delicate yes so you have to store them
in the refrigerator or at least cover
them so they stay dark otherwise they
will oxidize they will go bad on you oh
really
so this stuff is great because doesn't
go bad but it's very bad for you okay so
the healthy oils if you learn how to use
them take you a long way put some on my
heels and this is in a lot of things
this is the hydrogenated oil correct yes
this is hydrogenated to make it solid
okay and then by the word that you will
see in the package is a trans fat
because these hydrogen's bring these
molecules together and we call them
trans fat so I don't want the thing to
say hydrogenated and I don't want it to
say trans fat and I don't want it to say
saturated exactly you just hit the nail
on the head